So I think that you always
have such retarding moments
when they slow down the development a little bit,
that could be regulation,
it could also be that no one
really finds use cases, so you ca
n't get the toothpaste back in the tube,
I think you're up  On the hardware
side there is further improvement, the
number of parameters in the models
will continue to increase, at the same time
you will have better training data, the
software will be better, the computing power
will be better, so what we have in GPT today
will somehow be like
a 486 PC  occur or
so I think gpt5 will be much more
powerful again. Google will
certainly
bring out a more powerful model. Welcome to the OMR
podcast. Big annual
order series and what is the
tradition like with our regular guest
Philip PIP Klöckner. We had
dinner together last year and we had the years
before that too  We've sat together more often
during the year, of course, but we always talk about predictions at the beginning of the
year, especially PIP, and
the KÜS has
already expressed a lot of thoughts in the Doppelgänger podcast
um the good order is to
first
recapitulate, so to speak, what we said last year
and a few things
were quite good a few were quite
bad first of all hi PIP happy new
year yes exactly happy new year of course m
so let's start you have
Seen beforehand, it's going to be a difficult year for Sara's companies,
so 23 and that's how it
turned out. I would say that we
derived it in such a way that many
companies bill seed-based, so sales for wares,
for example, they grew by 14% back then
and then it's just difficult
if  People are being fired everywhere,
selling more seats or
selling more licenses and
I think the growth of csfor also
went down to single digits
Back then,
as they say, the topic of the
year will almost be a super
lame prediction in retrospect, but yes, that's how it
happened. You have to say it was
a different time back then. You have to go back to
the problem with predictions when they
arrive  They look so
simple but it was at the time when
chgpt had just come out, exactly
November 22 was the
Cambrian explosion where everything
developed, so it was still a
month and a half old back then and there were a lot of
voices that said the statistical
parrot and so on  There were also a lot of critics
back then, but in
hindsight it sounds more than obvious. Yes,
I complained a bit back then
that there
were somehow no use cases yet and I
have to say that there were
hardly any in 23, so a few like that,
write to me  Maline speech or or
somehow but the really
monetizable USS cases
we can talk about it when we
talk about 24 for the next one but
first of all that was that then we
both guessed that there wouldn't be any big
lung waves on Twitter
that was also a big one back then  Topic: I
think there have already been waves of layoffs,
but not now with the
brutality like on Twitter, where
somehow 80% were let go, so I
think there were smaller waves of layoffs compared to
what was hired in previous years,
yes,
I think in Europe  actually hardly
except for startups really
have the financing constraints in the USA,
the big tech companies have laid off what
they hired in 23 22 23
but now no big
waves of layoffs I would say
then I was completely bullish on this
creator economy and I said that before
There will be a Creator Unicorn in
Germany because the quality Group
ESN had Chris Wolf in
mind, for example. You have to say that there has
n't really been a Unicorn in this area yet. Chris Wolf himself as the
founder also had a difficult year, there
was a big one  Reportage at the
neomagazin ZDF about what's going wrong
Razia at the same time and I say this as
someone who is invested in the company, um, the
company has
continued to grow and is probably
a unicorn, but not an absolute
resounding success in the sense that
we wouldn't have had that before  can
see or that it
was already a very good company before, it has
just continued to grow but there is nothing
new like that or have you seen anything
influencer brands that are now at the same
level not really
not there have been attempts so the
influencers  Economy is definitely
still innovative, there is LCH that has
done this pizza business
but at the same time Mr Be has
discontinued his fast food line, I think because
of the supposedly premium quality,
I would say a bit of mixed back
but there will certainly be
news coming out again and again  the direction
yes, yes, I would like to know what
all of pamel reif's companies
are worth, so it's really difficult
to assess from the outside. I think there's
really relevant business behind it,
but
yes, you can hardly really see it
then we talked about them  um
relevance of
oil money so money from medium medium medium
burden and I would have guessed that it
simply pushes the entire relevance of the
region forward so also in in in in the in
the tech topics in the in the
mainstream business topics and
there  I would say it looks relatively
simple, but that's how it happened,
I think Ronaldo had already
moved there, but now the whole
planned merger is with the Golfour PGA
and these lifts will be the de facto
owners of the PGA Tour if everything works out  There
are numerous new events that are
being held in Saudi Arabia, for example there
is somehow a websummit in
Qatar, so there was just a
backlash now somehow around the
websummit and the whole war, but
also when you look at the war, it
just plays a role  that are now
suddenly taking over these states there,
that is much more relevant, much more
noticeable than at least in
previous years, I think so, and
according to reports, the whole thing is
in Silica Valley in the for seasons in R uh
they say like they say  you put the
handle in your hand precisely because
even the biggest, most renowned ones
from the USA are trying to fill their funds
with Saudi money, so I
think that the relevance of
the entire region has increased significantly.
Yes, so that's the only one
Emails that became public from the
PY cosgrave who, in the context of this
outbreak of war
around Israel,
um, who then turned negative or
very difficult to
assess exactly, but in any case there was a
lot of discussion and an
email was made public
where he tried to lure American
investors to his websamit in Qatar
with the note hey come back
to Qatar to give a lecture here, there
are a lot of investors
who I also want to get to know who are
interested in investing and if
that's what you want then  Then you could
get a bit of a feel for how they're trying to
bring the Arab investors and the American fund operators together, so to speak. Yes, I can definitely
understand better why you're here
in your role as Switzerland, so to speak  Maybe it's a
good fit because if you think about it,
say what kind of backlash it was,
then he simply expressed himself very
carefully and expressed himself unhappy about
this conflict or
took a side that not everyone
understands
I think he was particularly smart
and then it put his business
in danger, so to be
fair, 80% belonged to him. He then
resigned as CEO, but
ultimately the company stayed with him,
but you can see how
politicized it is  will yes yes yes so that's that and um
exactly so that that but
in the end it's the role of
Arab money is certainly increasing
whether you think it's good or bad but
I think the thesis is true, so to speak, which
I didn't agree with  I even
speculated a bit that this
could somehow be a way for Elon
Musk to somehow continue with Twitter,
that perhaps
Arab investors
could be won over, that didn't happen that way, yes there
are already some in there, even no,
I think one
I think Qatar or PIF has a small portion, i.e. the
Saudis, but it hasn't
come in yet. I also think that it's
no longer for sale, the
company to be honest, so who would
take over it because it's just
not that easy to run it now?
not Elon Musk, yes, I think with
the small staff base it
works, I think with
the work ethic that Elon Musk
exemplifies or enforces,
maybe everything just works, but I
think if a corporate
investor were to take it over now,
the costs would quickly be recovered  The
question is whether the costs will rise again as to whether more advertising money will come back in. So in the end it is now a
company really without a business model, so
advertising is
now I think in the end
Twitter will somehow be merged with other services
or maybe it will
manage to do that
We'll see over time that we'll be able to build a great app out there. I'd be
confident in it as what it used to be has
become increasingly unsuitable. I'd
say in general we haven't talked about it,
but despite everything, it's a good year for Elon Musk
So that's the crazy thing
that they certainly lost value in
the takeover back then 44 billion now
the thing is maybe still worth I
don't know anything between 5 and 10
maybe if at all so on
paper he lost a lot of money
but Twitter has  SpaceX is doubling,
you hear that now there is such a mega
apology that Tesla has doubled in size
last year. SpaceX is
now hearing that there is supposed to be a private funding round on the stock exchange that is
somehow in the range of I do
n't know, somewhere between 150 and 200
billion  So an incredible amount of money
for a private round, so for him
too, all-time high, already a good year, purely in terms
of assets, certainly
one of the successful years for his
reputation,
certainly complicated, positive and
negative aspects, so I think the
negative ones outweighed the negatives a bit
at the same time  The Walter Isaacsen
book probably helped him to
become a bit more approachable. It was
probably very clever that it
came out this year.
Yes, I think if you've
read it, of course I really
think you should read this book, it
's really really interesting  Really
being without a fan now, it's just interesting
what happened there, how he did it, what's
behind it and who
plays a role in it, so many good
stories, anecdotes
and when you read the book or what impression
you get of him
then he would probably say yes, it
was a pretty good year, we
somehow got it
as far as we wanted
and then that's probably
for him, you have to make it clear to yourself
that that's really how he looks  Now
on something like that, the financial aspect is
n't that important to him, all these Twitter
side effects, okay coming and going,
I think in the end what's really
important to him is the question of how close
are you to this custom flight or
moon flight with the Starship
and that  At least it looks
better now. In any
case, he doesn't seem to worry much about
other aspects anymore.
His appearance at the New York Times
dealbook conference showed a little bit
how important
other people's opinions are to him, in particular  of
the advertisers, so
I think he's pursuing his own
goals or what he believes
is right for humanity and
all these Optimus robots with Tesla. I
think it's fair to
say that we've
already seen something over the last year  So his
moral compass is that he
somehow went through the dispute with Disney
because Disney withdrew the advertiser funds,
he deleted the Disney
app on the Tesla
platform and so on so
ummup that you can do it so
that the IR so you can see it exists  There are
no boundaries at all between these
companies, so if you
are a Tesla shareholder, you also suffer from what
happens on
builds
autonomous robots,
like builds
rockets, does a lot, so
first of all, a lot of innovative power, say and
economic power that it generated,
but of course also a lot of power in
one hand and actually without any
overside, no, there are no
effective boards in any of the companies
that do that
So after 2023 you could
get a bit scared, I think
on the other hand, so this
overside, I agree with you, that's
generally a problem now
independently but of
course you'll get it even if you
act like he does  such big
leaps to the point where you can get so far forward, there are also
places in the book where he describes how he
bought Twitter, then he brings in people
from Tesla and SpaceX and they are
simply withdrawn from one day to the next, so to speak.
Winner about that  You can also ask
questions like, hey, they're all
separate companies, why can people
just go back and forth like that, but it
all seems to work and that's how
you make progress if you
can make decisions very, very quickly, very directly  It's always
so pros and cons, the overside is missing and
the risk is there. On the other hand,
the progress is just so great
that it can be achieved somehow
and I think it has, at least
often,
that comes in the book  stay out of it
and I think that's why
the book is a good compass for him, or at
least he had a real compass or at least
I don't know if it's still like that, but he
also co-founded this open AI company
in order to consciously create open AI,
so not  as a kind of
company project where someone does something of their own with
this dangerous technology
SN where it belongs in everyone
and he is totally crossed with Larry
Page at Google because he says because he
says he would somehow try
to own it and there somehow open AI
or  to misuse ai in general and
he doesn't have a feeling for the risks and he's very
risk-aware and he's worried about
humanity. He's worried about
humanity, so
you have to acknowledge that too
% admit that he believes that he is
acting in the best interests of humanity, but on the Open AI topic,
in the context of saying to Babu what
came about with Sam, it also
became clear that Elon Musk also
wanted to become CEO of openi and say why
He is no longer involved in the
company, among other things, so to speak. There was
probably an attempt where he tried to
become CEO of OPI and after that he
said you could do it on your own, just
as they didn't want to do it with him,
but yes, originally he did  seen the danger
that is for founding
a new ai company this year ne exactly
xci
xci also with the
thesis he is worried and it has to be
done according to his principle so
I believe him a little bit that
he is somehow worried and that he  If you
want to make the world better, there are
various examples in the book for yes,
but the question is, is that
simply meant in a nice way or is that a
God complex if you believe you are the
only one who knows what
is right for the future of humanity and
also  Others are a bit of a fascist
Zigo the S that he somehow tries to pre-produce himself with
a dozen different
women and because
he believes his DNA
is more valuable than that of other people
and so on,
but he also said I think he
believes in reproduction in general and  is
important, that's exactly what he calls the biggest problem
and then if you
look in the book where the children
come from then of course
it's totally bizarre for normal people,
like with a lot of surrogate mothers
and how many different women but
what  Yes, it's really awesome, he has
a child who has, so to speak,
changed gender, which has
a lot of conflict with him, which he also seems to
suffer from a lot, but I
think he somehow has three or four
children who are all so incredibly gifted,
so they all are  So somehow I do
n't know at 16 you can
do some kind of tests that you
can normalize if you have Sanford
somehow completed some kind of math
so he really has to
spread some blatant genes there but I'm
wondering if those are his genes or if he
's so Rogate  has chosen the one who
carries this on particularly well and I do
n't know whether he has these children now
because he believes his own genes are so
important in general and believes in that
I haven't read that book
but of course it can still be and at the
same time  It's
impressive what kind of talents are
emerging in his entourage,
but they have drifted very, very much,
so in any case Arab
money has not been a solution for
Twitter this year last year
then we talked about unicorns
are there now
or were there now there are more than today
last year and if you're honest,
we just said in the preliminary conversation that there
are probably
fewer, you were right because because of
all the evaluation logic, it's not that
noticeable when Unicorn Ear is no longer one,
um but there were actually
very few new ones before all of this  only three
new ones were added or maybe four,
and none of them really visibly
disappeared, but, well, they disappeared,
or if you
could honestly see through it, probably
a few attentive listeners already know
that it's relatively easy
to prevent the death of a unicorn, so to speak
You do structured rounds when it comes to
financing, which is why there are real
downrounds where the valuation drops,
but it can be
assumed that in the internal
valuation, many previous
unicorns
have been written off a bit, at least internally, and
at the same time there are a few new ones
dieepel and Al Alpha certainly big
rounds in 1.5° exactly
m otherwise there was little Unicorn
creation this year but it's
not a big surprise um
so you were right then
we talked about
Sam's prison sentence
that will be bankmanfed  probably
be longer than 10 years anyway we
talked about inflation recession
not so exciting anymore it's all
consciously clear as it was
the bubble of the klammetech startups bursts it
hasn't actually burst yes
it's not the freezing of some
funding programs now I think
been bad for the sector
overall, um due to the budget freeze,
so to speak, and now adhering to the
debt brake, that doesn't help, but
I wouldn't say that some
bubble is bursting or something like that, yes, yes, especially since
Marvel Fusion and things like that are
also in the end  s a Kim with companies
he had a good year
1.5° have also just talked about it
also rather a good year npal also
grew strongly last year yes, um
then you spoke about another trade
and also
predicted a difficult year for trade
I think that's how it
happened. Zando and about you have
halved their market value again in terms of market value. It's been
pretty brutal. We
explained, so to speak, why the
large inventories - the companies
all ordered their next collection during the boom
and with
higher sales figures  calculated and
then the inventory builds up a bit
and that usually leads
to low margins because you
have to sell with discounts to
get rid of it, as you can now see very well
at about you, the margin
fell to 35% last quarter  There is
little gross margin for trading and
I think just under 37 is not
great either and accordingly the
sales growth and the
price also developed.
You asked me, is there
any stock that I
would take from the trading sector or
fashion sector and I  I said if
anything then on and they have
actually developed quite well,
50% plus, almost like the good
tech stocks, Nestack has
risen by around 100 50% this year.
They have actually continued to
develop very well, although they are also a
bit high  Inventories had at the beginning
of the year but then
continued to grow very dynamically yes and
I
said okay yes I also believe
in Boss and Adidas Boss is
generally an
important stock for me now because it is
simply proof that someone  who
was in the podcast afterwards and
became even more successful and Daniel
Grieder was a guest a year and a half ago
or so, the CEO of Boss
and
since then Boss has made really crazy
progress, last year at least
another 15%
plus adidas 25% plus  There hasn't been anyone
on the podcast yet, one of the goals for the year is to
have someone from Adidas, of course, the börn Gullen, the new CEO podcast, let's see if it
works exactly
and then you can still say that we
both trimmed, we didn't do anything in the
episode last year  We
actually almost overlooked the fact that the year
23 turned out to be a Chinese trading year
where it was an issue everywhere,
but not for us. We
somehow didn't keep an eye on it.
Yes, I think last year we had it at
Alex's cash register zone
Talked about it a bit, it's a
regular topic, but I think it was definitely
one of the big trends. It
's also what significantly influenced the advertising sales of the
major social networks and Google
this year,
so without them they would
probably have a whole percent less
grew quickly,
so what Shin and temu and Alibaba
spend on advertising in the western world is driving the market very strongly.
I think Shin will probably
not be a big prediction now, but
IPO next year, you can already
read that everywhere, this year it will
probably be around 30 billion  Having
achieved sales and being profitable is
what surprises many people,
so I think at a very high
level you can say that this is ultimately
the most efficient form of trading or
making or providing consumption because
you have to ask yourself in the
digitalized world what functions do
retailers have  actually still that you ca
n't map, so to speak, through data
and through clever logistics and
then there's just little left and
why shouldn't the Chinese traders
sell their goods directly
in Europe of course then you should
pay attention to standards there should be a fairer
logistics regulation there should be fairer ones
There are tax regulations, everything has to be
clarified first, but in the end
this is the more efficient system than
temporarily storing any in Europe with dealers and
leaving it to the
data and real-time feedback that can actually be provided
these days, so what you need
somehow, so brands have them  yes,
no, no, I mean, you don't buy
any brands. I think it will
stay that way, that in the end you'll end up
buying very, very cheaply. Maybe it
will gradually become a little more expensive, but
I don't think that any
brands will ever be there in the next few years  Putting
clothes in
would basically be signed,
so brands tend to have it
easier so the first losers
will be fennig or
eurostores or seann NKD Kick
something like that then maybe later Sara Buhu
but there are also experiments Alibaba
is doing in Spain what I believe  miravia
or something like that, where they use exactly that
as a trick, so they sell
branded items with discounts in order to
mix in Chinese goods with high margins, so I don't think
that they can and have to grow with this alone with chin and so on
I think they will more or less
get brands on the market at some point, but at the moment I think
a brand would make a mistake
to present itself in that environment, but
at some point I think the firewall will come down
and then a
domino effect could set in  I ca
n't afford
to be active there anymore. I think that's a bit on the
brink. That
's one scenario, say if you're Berish
for Temu, you could say that people
learn that the quality is crap and
nobody orders there a third time  er
the bullish scenario would be the acceptance
is high enough that at some point it will become so
important that brands will no
longer be able to fully penetrate it, so you have
the account there, you have the One Click
Shop service, they
have the distribution, they have one of those
Infrastructure built that you
can't get past and then it's
easy then it grows from the bottom
up that could be exactly the case
and it doesn't have to
work in eendorf, so to speak, it just has to
in welhelsburg Spain  In Italy in
Saudi Arabia the biggest sales are
made by the platform in
South America and in countries with such
low household incomes and for them
it was probably a very good alternative compared to
the brands where they typically
stock up
Let's go, I
find your thesis really difficult
m yes, I have a few
predictions on topics that I
have the feeling are closer to me than I am now, to
overlook this Chinese trade, especially since
regulatory issues also
play a role somehow, I think something
I will continue, so to speak,
that there is a lot of advertising money
pushing into the market from that direction, so when you
talk to platforms, be it the large
or smaller medium-sized
e-commerce platforms, they all feel
that the largest advertising spend, so to
speak, is added net
definitely comes from China and to a
considerable
extent, so of course there are so
many issues still on the agenda, including
geopolitical risks. Now
everything seems to be easing up a bit again,
but it can also be different in half,
well, okay, we
talked about it and it's falling  It's difficult for me,
but you would rather draw if
the IPO came now, I would think
so, we have also learned in recent years
that it is not entirely smart
to always buy things at the IPO
if they have been in private hands for a long time  You
buy at the peak, so to speak.
I also believe that Schin urgently has to come
out next year. I do believe
that they will continue to grow, but
we probably have or will have the absolute peak of profitability and growth, so
I think we have
seen it in 2023  That wo
n't be an issue now and it depends on the
price. I'm guessing that they'll
be valued three times in terms of sales. That's
already not cheap, probably
Wacken again 30 40%, maybe
this year maybe a little
faster, but it's basically
nothing  What I would absolutely own in the long term
with Temu you would have to
look again that could be, so to speak, as it
is actually a pure
media platform if you want that, which
actually only sells reach to Chinese
dealers, so everything else
happens. They have no goods on the
balance sheat s we sell  actually
just forwards the customer
to the retailer within a second who
then sends it directly to the customer. In
principle it's almost like a tiktok, a
very similar business model just looks
a lot more like e-commerce.
I would have to look into that but
I can do it  Now don't say it with pride
if I somehow contributed 50% of it,
I wouldn't be
super happy that I'm somehow
sending plastic waste through a pipeline to Europe, okay then we have now
promised that the last one has been
completed to some extent, what do
you expect  For the next one,
of course, I think it will
be the talk, so to speak, in 2024.
I would
base a little bit on my hypotheses
that I also made in the
presentation at the OMR,
so that the models actually won't
be the big value driver,
but rather something real  modes or
who are also the shovel sellers for
AI hardware data and distribution
and I think there are
two exciting developments in the hardware sector and
one is that I think you can quite well
foresee that Microsoft in particular
but also perhaps
Amazon in the hyperscaler or cloud
computing area  further double-
digit growth will be over
20% driven by AI for Microsoft,
the openi deal has already
paid back 10 20 times in terms of the
market valuation that you
have gained and about your aure precisely
because a lot of it is used in the Microsoft cloud,
i.e. in Azure and
Microsoft clearly has the fastest
growing cloud business while
Google, for example, has real problems. The prediction
in the Doppelgangnger podcast that I
did was, for example, that I believe
that Google will probably have to forego margin so that
the cloud part
can continue to grow because they
are simply not that strong  That's
exactly what I mean, I think the cloud
is going to be super exciting this year, which
actually drove a lot last year,
but it's going to continue like this because it's
just now really
materializing, um, and the whole thing is
this shortage of computing power, so
these Nvidia chips are so terribly
scarce  and have also driven up the share price
very strongly, which also leads
to a lot of innovation in the hardware seektor
or something like that in the silicon sector or whatever you
want to call it, bärmetal,
um and I think on the one hand they will
try to make models smaller, so that
might come straight away  still on it but there
are also simply new ones. I think the
big tech companies will
integrate vertically, ultimately that means they
will build even more of their own ships, that's what
they're all already doing, so Amazon
has this trainum to
train models, inference chips to do the
inference  to make the prediction of the chips,
so to speak, the models efficient
and Graviton Chips Azure from
Microsoft has ENA and empere se
built its own chips. Google already built its own chips in 2016 so you
have to think about it 8
years ago they basically noticed that
hardware was becoming relevant and they have  These
super efficient tpus tensor processing
units were built. I think this will
continue, that perhaps even
more corporations will build their own ships.
Tesla also has its own chips
and simply to be less dependent on
this entire value chain from
Nvidia, but there are also
new ones  independent providers e.g. Z Brus is
an exciting new scale from what they
do is like write cerebras with
C in front c e B r a brass cerebras well
so you find W cerebras chip
you find that and what they do is
these chips are usually made like this
If there is a round one like that, they are like 12 in
this case like 12 inches so like a small
pizza the size and you punch
out the little chips out of it
normally and what cerebras does to
build computationally efficiently is that
instead of this, they are different from this wafer  To
punch chips and then
build out circuits, so to speak,
you take a whole wafer plate
and turn it into a large
supercomputer, so to speak, and this makes
communication much faster, super
exciting, no, you can
simply put it, it's like
connecting 500,000 MacBooks together and turning
them on  one task but the
communication between them is much, much
faster and you can train models
twice as cheaply and eight meters faster
and also much larger models
with many more tokens and so on and W this
company
that is still private also
financed Abu Dhabi Abu Dhabi  They are currently building
a vehicle that I think
is called G42 or something like that, they are building the first
supercomputer because they have 32
such wafer plates that each
have 850,000 cores connected together and
then somehow get 27
million cores and thus have these
two exflop performance, which is per
Second 10 to the 18th arithmetic operation
you have to do beforehand, it's all very difficult to grasp
but maybe half a million
macboxes that calculate something and
that means you have to say
so if you're not watching us here right now
you could follow this podcast on
YouTube PIP quotes everything  here
off the top of my head so that's kind of
sensational yes you
can calculate a model within minutes
so a 3 billion
or 7 billion model that
normally takes days sometimes weeks
you can calculate within minutes
that's super
exciting and mine  someone would have to
buy this company so I would be
surprised if I became one of the big
techfmen cerebras in
2024 but on the other hand there are
now if you look at the predictions of the
big techfionaires from the USA from
I don't know Scott Galloway of course
down to John Bartell but also
people  they somehow write for the
virge or others, I read everything through,
sometimes read across Fred
Wilson, so like there is almost
no one who doesn't publish some kind of PRS somewhere
A year could
now be 24, but rather a regulation is coming,
a court cases are coming where lawsuits
are being filed where maybe somehow
things have to be redefined again
where a bit of
disillusionment appears according to the motto that
so much money was invested that does
n't look at all  It looks like
a lot of these things are now
quickly getting close to money, of course the
really big ones are somehow, but many
others who have flown under the AI ​​halyp
will then perhaps become
clear, it is still very far away or
maybe nothing will happen at all
Now for the first time I think it's
a certain kind of thing, well,
how can you say it's not like
a big hype is expected,
but rather a certain braking mark,
so I think that you always
have such retarding moments
if they slow down the development a bit,
it could be regulation,
it could also be that no one can
really find use cases, although that's
compared to crypto or so
I think or metaverse, there are
a lot of obvious use cases here,
but
then yes, exactly  the whole copyright
issues that will become an issue. The New
York Times has just sued prominently
and has been able to prove very well how openi
really seems to be stealing texts,
um, but none of that will stop this
development, so you ca
n't get the toothpaste back in the tube,
I think you do  Do you have
further improvement on the hardware side?
You have further improvement in the number of parameters in
the models, it will continue to increase at
the same time you will
have better training data, the software
will be better, the computing power will be
better, I can see the zero as
it is now slowing down  or sometimes
regressions in between,
maybe but of course we will
say at the end of 2024, so what we
plan to have in GPT today will somehow
seem like a 486 PC or so I
think gpt5 will
be significantly more powerful. Google
will certainly
bring out an even more powerful model
Um, I think it will be a
prediction, not a prediction, but what becomes relatively clear
is that the open source community
will live very strongly again thanks to AI,
so there are many open source models
that are based on Lama, which of course
also ultimately affects the topic  In general,
however, there is an argument against a certain level
of monetization because that means that in
some ways
things will be free, and a lot of the
values ​​that you create with them will
simply not be able to be monetized, which
suggests that monetization is
not at the LLM or Foundation model
level  I think that
actually happens, which is why I try to
concentrate on hardware data and distribution or on the
application empty. I think that
in the end these models hardly have any modes.
The French startup Mistral has
made a model that essentially combines eight small
models  They are so efficient
and more economical, that is, you have to
imagine that in front of the model, when
the request comes, there is a kind of router that
says it is now a question that has to be answered by
the model, so now I have to do the
calculations, I have to summarize something,
I have to translate something and accordingly
Do I want a different model, so
that shows that from the open
source community or you can also download the model
from huging face? There
will be many similarly
powerful models. Mr. has
shown quite well how quickly you
can catch up if you think about it  how
much advance Google has or an
Open AI that a Mistral or entropic is
now relatively quickly getting very close
to
a great European hope no,
I haven't heard of that one, it's
probably a French company
where the best AI developers
So a lot of Europeans come together, a
lot of French people too, and that's a
huge
valuation right off the bat, I think they
called for 100 million after it was founded and now
the valuation continues to be high and you have
great hope for it  In theory,
Europe has a good base of talent
because all the deepmind developers
who have done the most research on AI in the
last 10 years were all sitting in
London at Google deepmind, so to speak, and
I think half of the founders of
Mistral also come from zon deep mind
and  Meta if I'm not mistaken, that
actually means we have staff
if we can keep them here, but you
also read what the salaries are, it
also came out this year that the
median developer at Open AI
earns around $00,000 a year
Of course, it's
not that easy to mess with it, um from Europe, but
I would agree that, um, yes, there
will be such recurrent moments,
um, I don't necessarily see the added value
at the LLM
level, um, and as I said, those who benefit the most
right now  Are they the
cloud hosts, so to speak, because it's all still
very, very computationally intensive, you can benefit from AI
as an investor if you want,
but then you're more likely to buy Nvidia or
buy some hyper scalers, um, rather than
any new companies
that aren't listed on the stock exchange yet anyway
Partly or
exactly or you invest in companies I
think the next
level of value creation will be
companies that already exist but
are still sufficiently innovative to
quickly incorporate this into their core value creation
in Salesforce or Adobe, for example,
Salesforce has had
these for a relatively long time  I think Einstein ai adobi
has their
own model that adds a lot of value and is integrated into Firefly
as a single product but also into the
other products.
I think what the
financial impact will be, whether they
can immediately benefit financially from it is another question, but they can
do it  I think it's a good idea
to stay on the cutting edge, so you remain
bullish on the overall topic of how
exactly you make it tangible in the market
or which numbers you have to look at
is difficult, probably most likely
the numbers of the
infrastructure companies around it, we
just talked about it  okay, so
further predictions, um maybe to
almost complete ai a bit,
I think what I'm really
looking forward to and what has
n't
been paid enough attention to is the connection between
AI and research, so ultimately research is
still super manual,
especially in pharmaceuticals  Chemistry
Materials Science That means you
test far too many things
manually and look until you
find something by chance and you
now realize how much AI can help.
There is this example that I think
Google deep into the 2 million
new crystalline structures
So you can imagine that we did
n't know about them before, so to speak, that's
43 times more molecules than humanity
knew to date and that can help, for example,
to replace certain parts in batteries
that are super heavy for us, like rare
earths or something like that, that's incredibly
difficult  The legends are
made available in sufficient quantities and perhaps
we can find alternative substances that
can solve problems in such chip research or battery research. Then there
is Alpha fold, which is also from deepm,
where you can simulate protein structures and
digital twins a bit,
that's what I believe  I'm really excited to
find out new structures, medications and so on and then the most
plastic example there are these
multi-resistant germs like MRSA the
meticillin-resistant stapilocus
stapilococcus aureus the big
demonstration of the brain of Pipi but
that's an AI you have to imagine
the one against meticticillin  is a
penicillin derivative, so to speak, that works against
conventional broad-spectrum antibiotics
based on penicillin or
cephalospurin, i.e. two of these fungi that
fight bacteria. There are
some that simply no
longer respond to it, which means you
get caught in the hospital in the
care facility. Hopefully
not, but you get it  You have a germ and
somehow you have a small abscess,
but it can also be that your hearing
is affected, your heart is affected, or you
end up with blood poisoning.
In the western world,
100,000 people die every year, often in
hospitals and often relatively out
of necessity,
and we don't have any  Antibiotics that
help against it or only very few and
now had what I think it was the most
with what they did is they
basically created a theoretical substance
that
can work. I think it was isolated from millions
of substances 280 that are
theoretically toxic
These mrssa
hospital germs can have an effect on these bacteria and of
these 280 you could reduce it to 280
and only with them you
went to the laboratory and
two different, so to speak, new
candidates came out that were
probably effective, so they were tested on mice and
effective against MS  RSA
were and where you can now almost immediately start with
clinical studies or relatively, by the way,
I somehow didn't quite hear it, it
reminds me a bit of a
podcast, a small podcast recommendation that
I listen to more regularly, called
plain English, do you know it? No, to be
honest, you don't know Thomson plain  English and
there's an episode from the
end of the year about the biggest
breakthroughs in science Happing
happening right now and
you can listen to it quite well, it's
not that long and then you understand
a little bit where you're coming from, so plain
English the Thomson generally quite an
exciting guy dererek Thompson also
wrote for theidentic for a long time or
maybe still does, so if you're
looking for a new podcast other than
Doppelgänger umr what else you can
find somewhere else, well okay so
understood breakthroughs in science are what you're
expecting  you too, thank you
ai ma continue so
now ai completed what else is there
yes I what else can I
complete I can't I think
that Apple could still have a good year
and that's because I think
they're slowly getting into the ai game now
My hypothesis is actually that there is
now a lot of research being done on new devices. There
is this human clip that you
can revamp as a new
device. All of these glasses should be
revived again, be it the
quest glasses from Meta or the Google
glasses, whether they might come back
or the apple glasses but ultimately they
are the airpods which are
already a very good business model
anyway actually a subscription model every day as often as
you
lose them they are the perfect
voice interface actually for AI so
if you would just give Siri gade
that might also be another
trend  slms i.e. so-called small llms
or small language models i.e. the
models will now also be smaller
so that they can run on a cell phone or
a MacBook and then
you can simply give Siri, which has been
really quite stupid so far,
a significant upgrade with
a small  language
model and then Apple could basically build a
very, very powerful AI chatbot
for the cell phone. I'm relatively
sure, by the way, what I also
learned in the book is that while we're all
looking for language models to
train their AI, the ones at Tesla are
really trying to use these camera images
The cars that they have millions of times,
so in every Tesla there is a
camera that records the journey, so to speak, to
use it for this purpose, so to speak back to
completely different
input values, so instead of
now, they go to pictures
of some vehicles and try to do so
afterwards  to model this self-driving
no longer so much according to
any rules but according to
real experience if somehow
a million times a car has stopped
when a cyclist came or so and so
swerved then somehow it now seems to
be learnable.
I found it interesting that you can  So to speak, you
can now think about what kind of
hardware you can
perhaps generate images because
at some point something else has to
feed them than just speech or yes, exactly so
there is one of the greatest thinkers in
our nation believes that Tesla is
the greatest  Kamp but let me
read briefly between the numbers I wanted to say I think it's about the
topic s yes I said data
distribution and hardware will be important
and I think having the best data for
something will be another
big advantage in 2024  I think there are
already marketplaces for
training, of course, where you
can say I would like to
see 10,000 traffic light images that are either red or green or that
have already been presented, say where the connotation
of a person is what you can see now  It's
already on it, but as I said, it's really
exciting if you had that for
rönkin pictures or something, so give me
100,000 rönkin pictures and it says
on them whether it was a carcinoma or
not and, as you say, quite rightly,
if you have machines where those
Data as waste is
of course worth its weight in gold, I believe, for the
near future, so I'll take a
quick break here or just end
the AI ​​journey for a moment, even if that's
of course exciting. I'll
try to see a little bit of
what I can still see  I'll come
up with a very simple thesis myself. I think we'll
see the Flixbus IPO next year. Do
you
also think it's very
likely? You have to see how
quickly you
can digest this Greyhound acquisition. They have
this legendary bus brand  uh or
long-distance bus brand taken over in the USA
uh you have to see how well you
can represent it as how much
organic growth is left and above
all they manage to get organic growth out of Greyhound
again
uh but in principle I
think they are of age uh there uh
I  For the purpose of
implementing it and so I think it's in the
right direction, the question is how much
damage have these 49 € tickets done to you now and so on, so to speak, so that there is
subsidized competition, so there is multiply
subsidized competition, so to speak,
but in terms of time, it would  fit and
I think what
they have built is also something impressive. I have
always said very positively about flixbus
here several times, so in my opinion a more worldly thesis a
bit for the non-scientist
maybe or not somehow ai
experts I WD already believe the IPO
window so that  Now the
first ones who have, so to speak, put their foot in the water
or put their toe in the water have
n't
gone particularly well yet,
what was there like odity and Birkenstocks
and so on, everything didn't go so well,
it will probably be
relatively back in the first half of the year  Say,
because I would have
mentioned that again now, I somehow
asked myself what can you generally
give for, say, storylines for observation? I don't want to
talk about tips, about big predictions,
but I have this odudity, we're talking
about a
M something  They end up selling
customiz cosmetics or
cosmetic
scents but they already have billions in IPO and from
my understanding it's not that far
away from what Flaconi does
and Flaconi is a very good
business that has also grown a lot in the
last few years  I didn't even
notice that at
halftime I think it was supposed to be bought for over a
billion,
but that
wasn't enough for the owner of Pro 7 and that's
why Pros7 kept it, but we
were offered a lot of money for it
at other times  but it
's also there, so I don't know the exact
numbers, but it
's several hundred million in sales,
they and they go to Pro7 and then
I'm okay, and I'm following Pro 7
too closely now because there's a media company
there, I have one  a little understanding
of and then you can see that they are now
on the verge of losing their unicorn
status, so we're talking about the
entire Pro7, I think the
current marketc is somehow 1.2
billion and there's something like
Flaconi in there with this odity  It
's not dissimilar to what
recently had a billion dollar valuation
or even had an IPO
and then he's still somehow
involved in this whole stake in parshipip
and in this whole
dating box there's Hal, the
television business in Austria
and Switzerland
In it join this streaming
platform where you can also ask what
is it worth but overall
the parts of pr7
now seem worth so much to me that you say
okay 1.2 billion valuation is
not that much
m and I actually thought maybe
one  Thesis
I then looked, okay, you can
also see that all the directors have
all bought recently, so no
huge sums now, but I think there are
three director dealings where
supervisors or board members of Pro7 all
bought their own shares in the region of €100,000  Um,
I thought, okay, it's almost
the next chance to earn money with pr7.
I actually didn't think so, but over the last 20 years I've
seen again and again that people
have earned a lot of money with pr7, from
halimsabah in the noughties
to a variety of things  other Permira
who somehow made money with it
and maybe it would work again, I
would have g that's no longer possible but now
at the value where they say it's
somehow now at the level of an almost
unicorn and with the assets
and m  Sales of so we are also talking
about the business in the must also
say again Pro 7 of I think over 4
billion total sales
of the evda, I also mean in the
range of 400 million so the P/E ratio would be then I do
n't know anything depending on how it is there
I don't know EBIT but
from 3 45 P/E on a business that is
of course shrinking, but what can be
saved so much money where there is so much
ETS in it so I could now here you
notice I'm coming I'm
just getting angry but I roof  I think
I actually saw a very
interesting stock, yes and odity
for comparison, I think it only makes a
little more than 400 million in sales
and is worth twice as much, so it's valued at
five times sales,
whether that's a bottle or something needs to be
discussed first  Is it fair at audity
that it is now
valued at fivem in terms of sales because actually the
numbers the growth is down to 37%
and profitm is only about
10% that is above all the AI
storytelling at the moment but to be
fair they have halved
the IPO and are now
almost back on the IPO course, so we've gotten
a bit
caught up again. Comparatively speaking, pro 7 must of
course look very cheap. I
think there were also a few
changes in personnel, Martin Milner
moved there from United Internet or Jonas, no  Financial situation, yes, that's exactly what
I saw with the director, I
also bought it first. I looked at the books,
okay, it seems to be cheap
I have quite a lot of debt
GL, I owe over a billion
and now with the new interest rates I have
n't looked into the refinancing,
but I still find 1.2 billion
market cap with 3,400 million earnings
with 4 billion sales for assets like
FL KI  I'm now um
already forecast value I would
say at the end of the year 24 Pro7 will be more
than today I could well imagine
just because the advertising market is coming back
the interest rates will go down that
all that should help I can well
imagine that to be honest I
actually have one  Very healthy operating
cash flow comes out over a billion,
but we have also accumulated debts diligently, and we have
n't
talked about it on a podcast, and they
actually have an edge when
it comes to
reaching relatively young people on television
which is the average age of
linear television so at ZDF and
ad really it's over 70
sometimes on average no so not
s so really like the average is
already at 70 and if you even
want to reach people under 40 is Pro
7 and a certain  scale,
then Pro 7 is actually one of the
best ways to get there, there are no
assets in it, so I mean all the
shows, they are somehow
assets that you also
have as such, so now from
Top Model and and and  also the new
things from Joko wer Stüber the show so
you always manage
to get people together, even the younger ones
now or the not so old ones
at least yes I think that's
very cheap now and then there are
these, let's say expert stores
Now I'm calling the Berellusconi
family, who have been
making television for decades, who
have now bought a share and a
Czech billionaire. I do
n't think they're people who
somehow just
have so much money from a distance, they know
this business and  I think they
would like to take over that, those who
hope that they can get to it because they
just see so much upside,
so there are also fantasies
that could be interpreted into it
that I would say the thing could
easily be worth twice as much, no
Yes, it looks W if you don't believe that
television dies overnight, you
see exactly that. You've
seen it quite well in the magazine market or the print market, how it typically
works. If you're a media expert, you would do
something like join, so you give it
a chance to join  Is it worth it?
I'm totally new to the numbers. It's
hard to get it right. I think it's difficult. In the end,
Hal is the question of what can be. It
should now be a billion-dollar business
like television used to be
I think it's super difficult but
can it still be a profitable business?
You have your streaming platform,
you primarily produce local
content and you build up a
circle of subscribers over time where the math
and an advertising business are worth it,
both um I can imagine
why  because not so why should
n't that work, you can
expect that and of course a
Netflix somehow comes with local content
and so on but why shouldn't that work
the only reason why it might
be more difficult in Germany is
the public media libraries
but otherwise it would  I
say that
you have a streaming platform that is
not expensive, so running it,
the git, is a question of content
and and yes, but the question is whether the
R&D investment is what you need to
run it and that
is customer acquisition  it's more expensive as if
you wouldn't just say I'm selling it
through Amazon Prime, so I'm just
offering a channel in Amazon Prime and putting a
lot of my content in there and
then passing on 30% of the revenue to Amazon.
I don't know what it
looks like now  I guess somehow
30% whether that isn't the more
efficient model, so to speak, to use your values
to use your rights yes,
I think so,
yes there will be a big discussion
about the
media libraries but in the end I think that
you have a stream platform like that
should already be able to operate but on niau
now not worth billions but
is from
on the other side which
also made me skeptical now I had the
woman M Hofem i.e. KR Hofem who
is now the boss of Netflix Germany was
formerly responsible for join at Pro7
and  I was able to get a little bit
out of it, I think it's one of the
most successful shows Jerks h this
format is the only reason why I
joined, by the way, with Chrul and so on. Actually, a
lot of people in our bubble watch it and I understand that,
um, that that  somehow you
have that now and I know some people
like to watch it now but is it
somehow that made me rather skeptical
as to whether that somehow speaks for a
certain relevance of join across
the population because Jerks
is just a thing for a certain number of people
Bubble and it's small so it's
not what the rest of the
country is watching now, so Christian Ulm and so on
or the topics that are being done
there are small influencers or
small personalities compared to
the stars from other trash shows
or something like that and that's why
I was like that when I heard that. Human join
is so important. Human jerk is so important
for join. I thought to myself, okay, that's
actually not a good sign that there's
exclusive somewhere else, so
obviously, but it's just but it
should somehow  Nice phonic
icing on the cake for join and not
the substance, so I would have thought that
you would have to get substance from somewhere else,
that somehow Jerks would still be the COO
to bring people like you in,
but that's just that it's
one of the growth engines, so to speak, for the
entire platform  So that's how
I feel about it too I guess that
made me skeptical at first because you need
mass, you need millions of
subscribers and Jerks can't
deliver that, that's why I thought so, if
that's the biggest thing then the whole thing ca
n't be done  I really know what I mean,
on the one hand I'm surprised at how
relevant it is but at the same time
I can understand it very well but it
's also because there's
actually very little other content
on Pro7 that interests me. I was
just thinking about whether it's the jungle camp
or something like that  Isn't that
really cool for streaming from RTL plus? You
can say that here you get
an extra camera and the nude picture
and so on, that's how it works, or
Kora Schumacher threw up here, it
's only available in streaming on RTL plus, I
think  You can get people across quite well
with such
formats because you haven't had jungle camp until today.
You actually have to
invent it for streaming, but
I think jungle camp or things or just
imagine that television did
n't exist until now and it would  If there is
a new innovation that means you
somehow have the opportunity to
stream something live directly into
people's houses in front of the sofas of
millions of people then you would
say okay wow that's
pretty cool so it's not
streaming somehow  Yes, live streaming and so
on, what you could do and
everyone can watch at the same time
and so the whole connotation of television
is just so negative now that
you think that's that's that's old and that's
dead now and that's true too
on the very, very large numbers
but I think it also has a certain
justification, especially with formats like
jungle camp where
everyone is talking about it at work. You
watched it last night and then there is
a phase of the year where you watch it and then there is
the next phase of the year where you
somehow watch Heidy kum
where you watch football W you
watch the Olympics this year so there
are still 10 15 big TV
events spread across the channels and if
you think about it now  with a
more positive, modern framing
and it's not like that, but it's from yesterday. They
also made this
strange box in the 60s where it used to
come out in black and white, everything dies
on a large level,
but everything dies on a small level,
I think  That's attractive and that's also why
I'm actually bullish on things like this in the
sense that if they're
suddenly only worth a billion
D I say okay what I just
said then you can look at it, I
think now that you can do it like that
RTL can make 4 5 billion in the best years,
I do
n't think that was somehow monstrous,
what the long years pulled out of the
RTL group, that's going away,
but you always have to
maintain the proportions a bit, you know, I
would like it  We assume that we will
see a new crypto cycle again in 2024,
driven a bit by
the new ETFs and the havvening,
so that it will become even more difficult again
or there will be another crunch,
Hal has already moved up very strongly,
the price has moved up again
Last year, however, I would
also tend to believe that at
least in between we would see courses
well over 50 or 60,000 at the
bit bin, which doesn't at all
reflect my belief in the industry behind it. I
still think that there is a use case missing,
but I believe it  I'm more likely
that crypto will come back this year,
also due to lower interest rates, than that it
will go down again immediately, which is my
guess, especially since the big exchanges
are actually all of them, it's now
turned out that who frud who isn't
Binance has now caught Kraken itself,
I don't know what  That's the status
but the bad news is a
bit out of the market so how
can it get any worse, so to speak,
what you've heard from the crypto industry
and that's why I think there's more buying
surplus this year than the other way around,
yes I can well
imagine that too  Then I have another
forecast from the media sector, where
I feel somewhat confident,
and also based on stocks,
I am quite bullish on the New York
Times. We have just talked about the lawsuit
that there is
against open AI  There will be
some kind of payments.
I think we're looking at a great
election year in the world.
The New York Times is now really a
world product, no longer just a US product.
SN is really for the whole world and in
election years like this you want to know what's going on
When Trump actually comes,
you can almost hate and say that
the New York Times will really
experience an upward trend again because a
lot of people somehow
felt like that last time when
Trump came, then want to be informed differently and
then take a closer look at what  Wanting to go there, you get
a kind of
bewilderment and
somehow a new interest, a new
vigilance for politics and then it
usually turns into a New York Times
subscription and
then the old principle, which has been
going very well in the last few months,
I think that's the stock  A trend that is
still going on, if you're honest,
you're not just buying a
news company, but now
also a gaming company, which I also find attractive with
all their WLES and cross-word puzzles and
so on
I don't think it's seen that way;
many investors tend to look at a newspaper and not at a
gamingfma, which would have a completely different problem,
but that's de facto it to
some extent
and I would say that this mix
isn't exactly right now  cheap,
I have to take a look, I had
noted that down before, um, it costs almost 8
billion, exactly if you look at what kind of
value we just saw on Twitter,
um, then that's somehow, um,
quite interesting. Mark to P/E ratio is to the power of
41 or something like that  I've seen that,
of course, it's expensive,
um,
but don't argue against it that things can't
go even better, um, and that's just
such a great choice, yes,
with potentially
problematic yes, in the sense of the New York
Times's widest circle of readers, people
results,
um, that somehow in the end  which
gives the company a boost, so
to make a forecast that can
then be measured in 12 months,
I would say it will
noticeably increase in value in the year 24.
Yes, I can well imagine it,
I think that it will  The type of journalism
that the New York Times does that ca
n't be done with AI,
so you can definitely support it
and make it even more efficient,
but you definitely can't
replace it because it's first reporting
and investigative reporting and
something  You can also say that to the
extent that Twitter is now
kind of dying for many people because of
all the changes there,
they want to go somewhere else and get
information, and I now notice it in
myself, I'm now a subscriber to
the New York Times  and I do
n't go to Twitter
as often as I used to and I just go
into the New York Times app
and read something there and that helps you
in the end so that a large
news network, if you will,
might disappear now
Yes, no other social network
instead, so okay, there is
LinkedIn and there is still Instagram
and so on, but they have a different
function somewhere and I think this
news topic remains relevant and
then you look where do you get news
or do people in the world watch and
That's the New York Times, it's
almost a replacement for Twitter, I think
in certain respects and it's just
not like there's a new
network, so I'm
now pretty sure that
all these attempts are Blue Sky
or threats or
masodon none of them will work
would be my prediction but what
works more is at the end of the New York
Times and instead
a little bit of the users will shift
into other existing net networks
into LinkedIn or Instagram but
these new things that will  I do
n't think I'm going to hang on to that, I just want to say
what what what Twitter will
leave behind now and maybe soon and that
's a bit of the old thesis that
a social network really
is the creation of one. Somehow
I think it's a black swan event, it's
very rare  something like that happens and
you can't aspire to it, it's not
for manufactures it just has to happen you
need luck for it you need
early adapters for it you need
network effects all the things that can hardly be
produced in any way so at
least not like that you need new
technology quite often no so something
new  Medium and that's why
I think if I were to find the last argument
for the New Times, that the
slow becoming more irrelevant of
Twitter could be one of those things. Yes, I would have
almost said
the same thing
I've
never taken out as many paid content subscriptions
as I did this year, so
I've completed
all
of this
as well because I use it a lot to
prepare the podcast,
but I've completed all of this for the first time
I have
the information in the years before that, so I think
I've had it for a long time, but I
definitely have a lot of paid subscriptions. I
also think that this will be driven further by AI,
simply that you'll just
have a sponge of content that you'll probably
see yourself after  a few reliable
sources and are willing to pay for it
because you have everything else, be it
the spol on Twitter or whatever. You
will no longer be able to distinguish between Google News,
what is
real media, what is AI generated or
just simply rewritten, translated by
everyone  Now if you look for an article in the
newspaper you will usually find 3
4 f translations in some
countries that have simply translated it with eii.
I think that
people in the PID programs are more likely to
sense that I also and the other things that
I observe  I've never consumed as much
newsletter as I did this
year or subscribed to a new one and I think
that part of the whole Twittermkts is being
taken over by newsletters. There
were the pioneers somehow Ben Thomson
Evens um and so I
started one this year that's why
not  That's why it's a quick
short plug here where can you where can it's
first about TR I GLB newsletter
replace media and social networks to
a certain point
exactly I basically just for the
day we come with Doppelgänger podcast
yes on Wednesday and on  Out on Saturday and
it's often the case, for example, in this open ai situation
that the ordman
gets thrown out on the weekend and on Monday the
boss is back again.
We wouldn't have been able to get it in on Friday when we
record because
we just didn't know that it was going to
happen and  on Wednesday has
already rolled over three times and
the world looks three times different
and to fill that up a bit,
I'm now writing a Monday update,
so to speak, where it's just about the news of the
week, maybe a little bit about
what will be relevant next week
m  good podcast recommendation, a good
video recommendation,
that's it to fill the gap a bit,
but also because
the newsletter medium is becoming more relevant for myself
and there are a lot of people who say
do it via WhatsApp, or say
that's my point now  I'd
like to make
the
point straight away and I think we see too many
things so black and white. You can
of course say that you can't reach anyone
outside of messengers anymore and
I think that's partly true for a certain generation,
but if that's what it was
We're never
allowed to do this two-hour podcast or
it's already going to be wiag and
probably whoever I listen to people anyway,
I think there's a
counter-trend to every big trend or
there's a target group that's
a little smaller but the editing
Not everyone tries to make a podcast
under an hour because that's the
domestic flight rule and there
's also Lex Friedman
or Joe Rogen who somehow
make a 3,5 hour podcast
and that's why I always believe
that  a bit about the movement,
that's why I'm doing a very
old school thing but really why don't you do
WhatsApp because because I you you've
probably noticed I'm not a master of
the short format so to speak so it
's incredibly difficult for me to keep it short I
the newsletter is already a good one
School to make it shorter
but I think that I can reach the people I want to reach
better via newsletter, which doesn't mean that
I won't perhaps also add Peri WhatsApp
or Instagram Channel at some point
or somehow
on LinkedIn. I think the E is now
the inro  if you ever
need an introsa K a company that can do this very well
somehow yes Victoria
or something like that no no no so
other predictions have we
forgotten something else what do I still have it I
think it could
be another exciting antitrust year so if  This
deal or this process now
starts when it is mainly about Google
and the advertising market and whether
Google has broadened its monopoly
even further
by partnering with manufacturers
of end devices with browsers and so
on, then one consequence could be
that it is banned  to continue this deal with
Apple where they somehow
give Apple 15 billion a year to
simply fill up the standard search
and certain standard apps, so there
is also this deal with Samsung or with the Mozilla Foundation and that
could be exciting for Google if that were the
case  These traffic
acquisition costs would fall by several billion.
In the meantime, Google would become much more
profitable. I don't think Apple
could immediately
monetize it any other way. It would be that they make a deal
with Microsoft, which would also be rather unusual for Apple and
Apple, in turn,
is missing 15 billion in earnings
in relative terms  quickly
m that means if they don't somehow
manage to circumvent this deal or the
possible regulation and if
this regulation comes at all
it would on the one hand be even more exciting for Google in the short term,
a lot of money would be lost in the short term for Apple,
so I think that's Schmidt  has
already explained or something like that,
basically two monopolies agree that
one doesn't
get over 15 billion so that he doesn't think about searching and that's
why if you
click on something on your iPhone and
click on an advertising click on Google then
Apple gets it  because somehow I think 40 cents,
if I calculated correctly,
in the shoot and the deal could then
fall through and that would be
exciting again for the entire search market and
for the results from Google and Apple
and in principle you can see
that  As far as antitrust is concerned,
antitrust law has tightened up in the USA, so
many mergers are not being waved through
and so on, why VC
is bad for the startupmkt, because
exit channels are also disappearing a
little bit, but I think so,
I hope a little bit too
the big tech monopoly again, in
principle, I think they would be even more
powerful through AI, to be honest,
but I hope that a little bit of
antitrust helps to regulate that a little bit
I don't know, you
want to be more specific, but um, not much,
so this antitrust issue, so you
wonder why this deal
so obviously doesn't seem to
be fair that you
can just buy a monopoly or strengthen it even further,
you wonder
a bit why nothing is happening but
it could now come to that for the first time this year
I wouldn't
have a house on it if I had one so by the way
now again about the Elon
Musk book is quite funny
El Musk's mentor Larry Allison has to him  I've probably
once said that if there's one person you
shouldn't mess with, it's with
Apple because there were some
disputes about Twitter and how to
make it affordable, so when he
wanted to introduce Twitter's payment function for these verified accounts, then first  Well, once I
found out, [ __ ], I have to give
30% of it to Apple
and then says okay, then I'll call
Tim now, it makes a lot of
noise and then you have to
stay relaxed. Apple, I can do it quite
well, it can really hurt
Not smart, I also said in our podcast
that the most likely
solution for Twitter would
actually be Apple because if you
were to be as broken as
Twitter is right now they would definitely find offensive content,
which is the reason why
many apps are so prudish  So why you
can't show a nipple on Instagram
or something like that isn't on Instagram at all
but on Appleag if nudity is shown in the feed without
me actively choosing anything
then it shouldn't
be in the App Store simply put and I
'm sure Apple could
Somehow manage it, so to speak, so that
they say free speech is all
nice or something, but say you can't
dirty our AppStore with
such content but in the end it also shows that's how
I just thought
about
your thesis about the
need for regulation, perhaps something
for a position of power Apple has it
like that Oracle founder monster
billionaires say you have to be careful
you can't invest them they are what
you are just describing there is already
a shadow government in the
world somewhere so what Apple wants
you can do very, very strongly  push through
or
things will be decided almost government-like
and monopolies will then be built as just
described. I have an example with the
Google deal,
which I would change again if
Starlink became even more successful,
so to speak. Google
started moving backwards
into the internet a few years ago  integrate so that
they said we are now a
successful search engine
but now we become browser operators and we become
operating system operators with Android,
so the Chrome browser was
developed after that, then in my opinion we bought Android,
so to speak, so that the device manufacturer
can no longer block you, so with
Android  He owns the big market itself and
buys the rest from Apple.
The next level is the
ISP, the Internet service provider.
They also started with these
balloons, Google Loon, which is, if you
want, the predecessor of Starling. They
just thought it was a balloon  would be a good
solution and they made Google fiber,
such a broadband service
wasn't particularly
successful and so you have to
think very strategically about who can
actually cut me off? Apple and
Google have this brutal power through
the mobile devices among which then
Meta  e.g. or snap suffers very badly and
why the advertising models don't work so well
and if MA
somehow manages to change the polarity of a certain part of the world to
say Starlink or to
direct their communication through it, he of
course has power over the
cell phone manufacturers again because he
Then the ISP is the Internet service
provider but there are other
options so why in the
civilized world, at least not in the civilized world, you do
n't necessarily need these Sting things, especially
if he does it particularly
cheaply or particularly quickly
and has enough customers and what
you have learned this year is that he
will definitely use this power,
so if Tim Cooki comes along stupidly again,
so to speak, and he
has enough users on Starling then he would
say hey, it can happen tomorrow too
Apple devices sometimes
slow down a bit, he also
proved that on Twitter that he slowed down the New York
Times or a 5
second delay for certain media that
are not weighed, he either
made false security notices or,
say, artificial ones, i.e. violated net neutrality
they made it slower
and so on, that means he is
definitely able and wants to do it and
I think that's why it's super
important that Amazon continues to push forward with this Kuper project,
which I think
is one of the most exciting things of all because
Amazon is basically doing it  the connection between
communication media and commerce will be
able to be the cable business and the
Internet access biness a final
prediction and that means somehow you
think the year 24 could also be a year
of the project where Amazon
plays a role as a satellite operator
with the project ker it could be  yes
the problem is it takes a bit too
long that's probably more of a
prediction for 25 26 but I think they
'll push it hard. This is
one of the few projects that
has survived coastcutting at Amazon m
and the narrative is that Amazon makes 500
billion in sales  a little more
now and say to grow by 20%
you would need 100 billion more
but there are not that many markets in the
world that are 100 billion in size but
the US cable television market is
somehow 300-400 billion in size I think
and internet access would be too
Again somehow 400 500 billion
I think and W if you
bring it into your hands as an e-commerce company
and you can basically say anyone can
take the cable out of the television,
you now stick your Amazon fire TV
stick in and then you get it  You get a
discount on all TV channels or you can
subscribe to them individually, so you can say
I want to join today, this and HBO and
then I'll buy that on demand
and at the same time you learn
about the users' preferences and you
can show them advertising  exactly
to change your household preferences so
the guy knows that he always orders
this somehow and the pet food always orders
Animonda somehow on Amazon then
you say here try Purina I
think that's super valuable and
it's the only market next to
healthcare and maybe insurance where
Amazon  can get 100 billion out of it in the short term
okay okay okay then we're almost
through or so I who through we do
n't have to do it any longer do you have
anything else exciting no I kind of hope
that it might be a year for
Europe I could imagine
that  If things are going well,
the Olympics are pushing Europe forward, what
you can see is how they
want to stage it in
Paris after all the Olympic Games,
which really
weren't that cool in recent years anyway, partly because of Corona
Not so say
attractive countries from our point of view,
at least not now you suddenly have
the world that is in Paris or in Europe
and and there will also be what you
can see, they want to somehow
include the whole city then the
opening ceremony doesn't  in the stadium
but on the SEN then
the whole nation goes there on the ship
so in there so there are so many things that
I read there where I date okay
that would really be really cool in
combination with the knowledge that  Since
not everything is really cool in the USA
when you
look at the election that's
coming up now, it does
n't make you happy at all. Do you want to
give a priction? No, no, no, I
have no idea
and I think it's somehow yes  It's
very difficult to say something
meaningful, new and valuable given
our level of knowledge and
at least mine, but what you
definitely see is that you then think
okay Macron, is that somehow
cooler, the sunag is cooler? Olaf Scholz
is cooler
then  then maybe from this
overall point of view there is this negative mood
on Europe a
little bit because of the Olympics vi a
little bit of the Euro above all but also
because of the whole selection and realized e
wow that's really about the whole thing
and maybe you think okay it's not
that bad  It's as bad here as
you sometimes think, so I'm like, I
think Bo, everything is really
difficult here, only negative news
and then you read the M book and then
and that again to
mention here but there you have it  Feeling what's
going on there and what he's building there and
of course the USA instead of al are
all American companies, all the
value creation that he's driving forward, including
with Tesla,
you don't know whether it's all coming from there, but
if something comes from then it'll
all find it somehow  In American
structures instead of there, people are of course becoming
a little bit more
pessimistic here, but maybe
that's not a bad thing for
Europe, that the things that
are cool are being emphasized
a little bit again, especially now
in contrast to the things that are now
Unfortunately, they're not that good in the USA, although
I'm of course also a big US fan, that
's no question, so I think it's
a worthy conclusion with optimism
that leaves the listener with absolute
optimism and a bit of anticipation for
the
things that are to come  That with
the AI ​​company in France that
we talked about, maybe a good
Flixbus IPO, we're also talking
about maybe 3-4 billion
um zone is maybe already
where are they still considered a
German company then I don't even know
if they are  are not already so
half-Americanized yes I already have
an office in New York headquarters yes mhm yes
well um anyway I thought
I could sprinkle that in here again at the end um
in that sense um you
already said at the beginning for new things I thought so
Still
saved, happy new year, thank you for
being here again, I'm happy or I
hope we'll see each other here
and again in the podcast over the course of the year, maybe we'll
also fall into two concept episodes, by the
way, if anyone is listening here, we
have ideas or a desire for a concept episode  Last year we
talked about what the most successful
German entrepreneurs of all time were,
which were the most valuable companies
founded after 2000 in
Germany and ideas like that. Anyone who
has such ideas or wants us to
discuss any topics can send us or in that case
probably me  Email or a
message on LinkedIn on insta um we are
looking for topics and want to activate PIP here
again for one two concept sequences
and otherwise
speak like that and certainly here
under see if in doubt also at the
festival hopefully m talk about what
role you will play there  you
want to do the state of the art update again or what
should happen who can
find what thank you very much thank you very much ciao ciao [
music]
ciao let's
[music]
go